are you guys doing
we're doing pretty well
uh i'm gonna start with what you're
hearing i'm sure all day which is uh i
love the movie you guys are fantastic in
it um i just nothing but positive things
to say it must be a very tough day to do
press
it has been really nice some people are
so emotionally have been so
kind and vulnerable and
and also that people are in person doing
it again i think a lot of people have
been doing this for the first time today
so it feels like everyone's in a nice
being really nice to each other which is
nice yeah
one of the things that i found so cool
about this movie is how little
exposition uh there's no there's no
exposition dumps by anybody in this film
it's very sparse which i loved what was
it like reading the script for the first
time and sort of because it had to
read very different than a typical
script
i think there might have been a tiny bit
that was probably cut out don't you
think honestly a good amount because
from the script to now
i think
the editor peter and jane really
economized it and found something else
where they took away a lot of
explanation i think to give it a more
haunting
nerve-wracking quality
because yeah there were definitely more
scenes with jessie and i and they were
cut which i it makes sense it makes
sense when i saw the film because
sometimes i i
get sad if i saw something cut and with
this film i was like oh wow that makes
you don't need it and it makes it more
terrifying
um but it's all there anyway under under
it all
yeah and it's and it's i think
i always prefer
when you're figuring it out as the
story's unfolding rather than
being told everything up front you know
oh a hundred percent i i it's um what's
great about the film one of the many
things it's just it's not talking down
to the audience it's
so good the filmmaking um
i know that jane likes to have their her
actors prepare like doing in character
exercises and i'm just curious what was
it like what did she ask you guys to do
if you don't mind sharing i just
remembered something jane had me clean
her apartment that she was like
[Music]
and i'm actually a very clean jesse
knows like i'm a cleaner like i i'm just
like a good like it
she was like i jane was like i don't
clean very well and because i ran it in
you know i learned
you know how to make biscuits and things
like that which i'm not a cook but when
it came to cleaning i was like yeah i
got this [ __ ] i'm good at like she
wanted me to make a table nice and i i
was like this is no no problem but i
think it's so funny that she made me
like clean her living room this place
she was staying at with old-timey like
mops and things like that
yeah there was a
i mean just having the the two weeks
before starting to
rehearse and you know i mean i mean some
of it was was a little um
a little unorthodox but some of it was
just sort of
there's a lot of talking about the
history of the characters especially
with
george and phil and
what the dynamic was like with the
parents you know basically filling in
the blanks from the book and then
imagining different scenarios and doing
improvisations you know on that
so it was it was fun and
it definitely makes it easier on day one
because you feel like you know
it's already kind of been up on its feet
um the the ending of the film is the
first time we see your character's kiss
and i wanted to know it's like the first
time we see that sort of emotion um was
that in the script did jane talk to you
about that
i'm just curious of the significance
we she cut out a little scene of us
um
in bed together where we did kiss she
cut that out so it is it ends up being
in the film it does seem yeah that's now
it it's our first kiss which i'm sure
that was and it's such a beautiful shot
yeah through the window
um i'm sure that came out in the edit as
something that they they liked that they
didn't have that until the end that
that finally like the wicked witch is
dead a little bit
yeah that's sort of what it felt like
sure i got to stop there i'm just going
to say again congrats really great
talking with both of you thank you for
giving me your time thank you